[Music]
it's real treat to be here again
and this is well a philosophy of science
talk about why trust science and here
you see the team that I've been working
with me Jeremy Hardy and Ileana want to
ski and we're trying to write a book on
the subject what I'm interested in is
places where where we trust science at
the coalface where it's really
intersecting with what's happening in
the concrete real world I'm also
interested in why we trust more abstract
practices methods and claims of science
but I've had my eyes operated on with a
laser and I'm really realized how much I
was trusting science at that stage and
what why should I do this what why is it
a reasonable thing for me to be betting
on it and the answer is because here are
some of the standard answers that I
think aren't sufficient okay one of them
is because of the scientific method
another is because science is rigorous
third is science produces general truths
by generalizing from well tested results
and another is that science is objective
I actually got these I'm going to talk
about Sciences rigors well I extracted
these there are a number of agencies
many of them in America because you know
there's the issue of what do we teach
for science in the public schools
in state schools in America and so there
are a number of agencies that have tried
to tackle the question of what counts of
science but there's also some
legislation about what counts as
evidence for educational policies so a
number of agencies but also the American
Physical Society and some places in
Britain so I scanned all of that and I
came up with this list which is what
they say okay and as I say I don't think
that these are either singly or jointly
sufficient to pick out why trust science
and one of the things I've realised in
thinking about this issue is that it's
incredibly difficult to come up with a
demarcation criterion that sorts science
from non science but it's a lot easier
to give some account of what counts as
credible science and that'll do the job
it'll also do that job for in the US
what do you teach in school because
after all we don't want to be teaching
non credible science in school so it's a
little easier to tackle you know what
what makes for credibility and sort of
leaning towards what makes for
credibility and science as opposed to
theology or romance studies or something
like that so I've decided to try and
address the issue what makes for
credible trustworthy trust deserving
science and I think the I think that's
actually what these agencies were doing
I mean they were just talking about what
makes something scientific and maybe the
scientific method but objectivity is
something we cherish elsewhere so here's
a list though that I think is what I've
extracted of the kinds of things people
other people have said make for that
trustworthiness of science I can talk
about each of them but not in half an
hour so I'm gonna talk about rigorous
because it's one thing I've been writing
a lot about lately so rigorous results
okay or like I think of them now as like
diamonds okay
so that if you want to make a diamond if
you want to make a bracelet out of the
bracelet doesn't just consist of those
diamonds right the bracelet consists of
lots and lots of other stuff that's been
very craftily loan to gether tangled
together built together molded together
by a community of jewelers who know how
to do that have learned how to do this
thing and the the rigorous results are
like the little nuggets of diamonds that
go into that but the final product like
the credibility of the laser the
credibility that the laser is going to
admit a cool beam and burn my eyes is
based I mean it's like the and bracelet
that we as scientists mold outer using
among other things rigorous results so I
want to mention a story about
high-temperature superconductivity so
these are high-temperature
superconductors and the story is told by
Marilyn ado Keanu ko who's a philosopher
historian of science and she very
briefly there were two explanatory
mechanisms on offer this happened about
over a decade ago but there were two
explanatory mechanisms on offer about
what makes for what accounts for
high-temperature superconductivity it
turns out that the theory of what makes
for low temperature superconductivity
wasn't moving over to when you got
superconductors at higher temperatures
so what are the two there were two
explanatory mechanisms we don't care
exactly what they are it's the sort of
structure of the study there were
phonons or magnetic modes and there were
two warring camps who were very very
good at what they do and very dedicated
to these two alternative explanations
and then um so we're going to get a
result a rigorous result which is like
this diamond right it's
there was a rigorous result they got
some new 3d imaging and with the new
ability to do this 3d imaging they
discovered something called a cake okay
a kink and the energy curve and both
sides agreed that these experiments
rigorously showed a kink in the
dispersion curve so there was I mean
everyone this is really really let's say
rigorously done experiment and the fact
that there's a kink in the dispersion
curve um is thought to have been fairly
rigorously established okay so that's
like our piece of diamond
now here's what Marlena says um what's
fascinating is that each of the two
warring camps claim to account for the
same evidence that kink right they both
claimed that that kink was in support of
their theory and showed refuted the
other theory
so each took exactly the same diamond
and with different jewelers and
different additional materials they
built that diamond in the two totally
opposite opposing bracelets so I thought
that's just a nice illustration of how
the rigorous result it needs it can be
incorporated in exactly opposite for our
exactly opposite conclusions when we
want to do something more dramatic than
just you know you're not probably
terribly interested in kink and a
dispersion curve but I think we all will
eventually need to be interested in
high-temperature superconductivity and
getting it to work better for us okay so
so now remember we had this list that
science is credible because of these
various things and the next thing I had
just wanted to this illustrates as well
I mean I said I was going to focus on
the rigorous but it there's a little
story also evidence shows that we
science doesn't produce
truths by generalizing from well tested
results generalizing okay so there
you've got this kick and you might
generalize that if you ever do this
experiment again on the same materials
you'll get a cake that's well maybe you
think of that as generalizing but you
can't generalize from the rigorous
result to either of these explanatory
mechanisms that is again takes all of
this other material that itself then has
to be found to be credible and so forth
okay so that's the I'm not going to go
about science is objective or the
scientific method but we could discuss
those okay so um what more then if we
don't if it's if I think that those are
not separately sufficient which is all
I've talked about so far but you know
even piling them together they're not
enough to account for credibility we
need I think we need something more and
I'm not sure with what I add is enough
right but I think it's really important
to pay attention to the community which
is not news because people doing science
studies have talked about how Sciences
of community activity and philosophers
have worked a lot on in philosophers we
do theory of knowledge epistemology have
talked about how the the locus of
knowledge is not the individual but the
community that both gathers it and it
can only be possessed by the community
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit a I dot TV
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas